[Musique]
c'est le fléau de ce 21ème siècle la
chirurgie esthétique la chirurgie
esthétique est en plein boom qu'elle
soit simplement réparatrice ou purement
esthétique la chirurgie a exposé en
France et notamment du côté de nos amis
des stars est-ce que vous êtes passés
par la case
chirurgie esthétique j'ai jamais caché
alors ça oui oui tout à fait c'est vrai
qu'entre les retouches photos et les
différents filtres Instagram difficile
maintenant de se regarder au naturel
dans le miroir
et si certaines célébrités ou star de la
téléréalité ne s'engagent pas j'ai fait
la poitrine le nez de fois les lèvres le
coin des yeux Botox au front et des
facettes il y en a qu'on ne
soupçonnerait jamais d'avoir usé du
bistouri dernier exemple en date Karine
Le Marchand qui avoué avoir eu recours à
la chirurgie j'ai réparé ce qui n'allait
pas et je vis avec le reste évidemment
je n'ai plus la peau aussi ferme qu'à 25
ans mais je ne peux rien y faire plus
étonnant encore c'est dans les colonnes
de gala l'animateur Michel Drucker
annonçait à avoir retouché ses paupières
c'est génétique j'ai la gueule des
métèques d'Europe centrale avec des
pommettes très hautes ça évite que le
visage s'affaisse comme quoi même à 80
ans on peut vouloir soigner son physique
mais la chirurgie esthétique peut aussi
s'avérer dévastatrices il y a un an la
super modèle Linda Evangelista s'était
confiée sur ce douloureux épisode de sa
vie j'ai été brutalement défigurée par
la procédure de coolsculpting qui a
produit des effets inverse de ce qui
était promis c'est à travers une
couverture de magazines qu'elle avait
décidé d'arrêter de se cacher et de
faire passer un message dans certaines
célébrités en sont aujourd'hui devenu
véritablement addict alors les stars
sont-elles obligées de passer par la
cage chirurgie
1 2 1 2 1 2 3 4 8 bonjour bien merci
Docteur Gérald franchi est avec nous
merci beaucoup et ben ça vous aimera
grande chanteuse des années 90 et
énormément de succès aujourd'hui
comédienne aussi aussi au théâtre
merci beaucoup alors une troisième
vous dites vous avez commencé un petit
peu à vieillir ça chantait un peu moins
et vous êtes dit est-ce que du coup non
alors c'est pas ça du tout merci
je fais la médecine esthétique qui est
différent et il s'agit d'une Botox en
fait qui c'est très mal passé
peut-être l'attente que j'avais déjà
c'était pour mettre en garde c'est pas
pour être contre les injections de Botox
la chirurgie ou la médecine esthétique
du tout parce que c'est formidable quand
ça marche bien sûr mais il a des cas
d'exception comme moi ou il y a quelque
chose concrètement vous y allez vous
faites piquer qu'est-ce qui se passe
alors il a même 1er fois j'avais fait
déjà des messages ça c'est très bien
passé moi j'étais très très surpris
j'avais toujours l'impression que la
tête flottait au dessus de ma tête
d'accord et ça personne
oui je me sens suspendue en fait en 2006
je fais avec un autre personne donc
médecin donc bon j'avais fait avec le
chirurgien
j'avais fait quelques petits comblements
je me trouvais un peu alourdi d'accord
chez lui il va me faire un Botox pour me
rehausser tout ça
[Musique]
je suis quand même retournée chez le
médecin qui m'avait fait le Botox un
mois après il m'a dit oh là là mais
pourquoi vous êtes pas venu plus tôt je
sais que ce qu'il faut faire donc il m'a
injecté la cortisone d'accord bon moi
j'ai déjà été beaucoup traité par la
culture puisque je suis né allergique
donc en injectant injection les la
cortisone m'a dit vous allez voir dans
quelque chose ça va lâcher
ça commençait par du nœud je voyais le
front avec des tri des espèces de est-ce
contraction et oui effectivement comme
un Botox trois jours après je me
rappelle j'étais avec mon fils il était
petit au parc je m'allonge j'étais
fatiguée parce que ça c'est lourd peser
toujours garder cette poids et je sens
Tao des élastiques qui repartent dans
l'autre sens et puis
terrible donc je sens et puis ça
commence à couler du nez de l'eau de
l'eau mais de l'eau de l'eau de l'eau de
l'eau mais j'étais mais j'avais plus de
j'avais plus rien que du lot et je me
sentais vider de lissage
plutôt que lui après c'est lui qui m'a
quand même fait les injections
logiquement c'est un tout petit peu une
rare aujourd'hui par exemple aujourd'hui
là
donc tout l'eau elle est partie quand je
suis rentré chez moi je me sentais vidé
je me regarde dans la glace mais j'étais
plissée comme un chien Carlin
aujourd'hui juste aujourd'hui comment ça
va aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui est
qu'est-ce qu'elle est séquelles les
séquelles c'est après j'ai eu des
alourdissements du front j'ai toujours
été très à faire la compensation
musculaire
que ça parce que j'ai l'air d'aller bien
et c'est grâce au sport je veux dire
aussi à tout le monde essouffez-vous
transpirez et en activité sportive
ça me sauve aujourd'hui parce que suite
à un intervention dentaire parce que
j'ai plus dedans même je me chauffe des
billes de bâtiment pour me faire des
dons alors qu'une seule seconde parce
que j'aimerais qu'on comprenne parce
qu'effectivement sur ce plateau ce que
vous voulez faire aussi c'est la
chirurgie esthétique mais également
surtout en fait c'est la réparation de
mauvaise chirurgie esthétique c'est
aussi pour ça qu'on a adopter euh
docteur Francis absolument tranquille ok
moi toujours Bourgogne ça tout le temps
alors docteur jeter docteur c'est mieux
quand vous entendez un témoignage pareil
ça c'est des choses fréquentes que vous
obtenez votre cabinet ou pas du tout les
symptômes que j'ai jamais rencontré dans
ma vie d'accord j'ai fait depuis 22 ans
des centaines et des centaines de ce que
vous faites quoi exactement alors moi je
fais de la médecine esthétique
d'accordique et de la chirurgie
esthétique donc les usages et du corps
et de la chirurgie réparatrice
réparatrice là vous réparez justement
les erreurs de vos confrères lorsqu'il y
a une mauvaise chirurgie il s'agit pas
forcément il peut s'agir de de de choses
imparfaites il y a des
interviewsystiques mais il s'agit aussi
d'enfants qui sont nés avec des
déformations du visage terrible avec
c'est quel accident de tumeur etc mais
est-ce que vous avez vu par exemple que
depuis la téléréalité normalement et on
va partout aujourd'hui les filles
veulent des grosses LED d'abord
qu'est-ce qu'on vous demande de plus
maintenant avec la nouvelle génération
est-ce que c'est de plus en plus jeune
qu'est-ce qu'on vous demande le plus et
est-ce que vous savez dire non parce que
parfois je vais les médecins quand je
vois des jeunes filles qui sortent avec
des seins c'est pourquoi le médecin n'a
pas dit non c'est une très bonne
question merci et je me la pose aussi ah
je me la pose quand je viens voir quand
je veux des jeunes passions deviennent
me voir avec des seins démesurés des
lèvres démesurées en fait moi je leur
explique une chose c'est que
il ne faut pas faire ce qui n'existe pas
dans la nature c'est la chirurgie
esthétique c'est fait pour susciter le
désir et le désir il existe quand on a
déjà vu ça dans l'interf quand c'est que
pour une raison qu'on ignore en fait
quand ça n'existe pas dans la nature il
y a pas de désir donc si on on
surinjecte des lèvres si on met des
saints trop gros
[Musique]
c'est très intéressant c'est très
intéressant ce que vous dites ça c'est
caricatural donc moi il m'arrive très
fréquemment dissuader des jeunes
patientes ou des moins jeunes de d'aller
trop loin je leur dis attention à la
limite c'est le naturel gardons du
naturel je vais vous expliquer ce qui
fait qu'un visage est beau ce qu'une
silhouette ah dites moi ça m'intéresse
une silhouette il y a des règles par
exemple de profil le nez doit être en
avant de la lettre supérieure qui
elle-même est en avant inférieur qui est
le même est en avant du menton si cette
règle est pas respectée le visage est
pas harmonieux et la beauté c'est
l'harmonie il y a qu'une seule
définition de la beauté c'est c'est
mort non c'est bon bah ça c'est en avant
de là puis on avant de là c'est en avant
de là qui est en avant de là d'accord
c'est pas très bien merci donc moi
j'insiste toujours par exemple les
étudiants en médecine à à passer du
temps à faire une césure ce que je n'ai
pas fait moi et j'ai regretté je l'ai
appris par moi-même ce qui rend beau
qu'est-ce qui rend beau pour apprendre
ça il faut aller aux Beaux-Arts donc moi
je leur suggère de faire six mois un an
de stop dans leurs études quand ils
s'intéresse à la médecine à chirurgie
esthétique et d'aller aux Beaux-Arts
et pour le coup je vais faire parler
Benoit après parce que c'est hallucinant
aujourd'hui tout arrive non seulement la
téléréalité mais des États-Unis par
exemple même aujourd'hui que vous faites
un blanchiment des dents aux États-Unis
c'est une couleur qui n'existe pas dans
les manuels elle est blanche blanche et
je crois que depuis un an c'est interdit
en France mais aux États-Unis c'est
c'est ils n'ont pas du tout la même
notion de la chirurgie esthétique ils
n'ont pas de limite moi j'ai travaillé
aux États-Unis et en Floride j'ai été
formé en partie là-bas et vraiment je
regarde ça un très bon souvenir parce
que tout n'est dans l'excès c'est-à-dire
que je me souviens d'une jeune femme de
20 ans qui avait un beau visage et qui
vient avec une photo de Sophia Loren oui
je veux et même pommettes m'ont beaucoup
plus gros et le chirurgien accepté alors
que il aurait dû refuser il aurait dû
expliquer non vous avez un beau visage
restez comme ça on peut éventuellement
de Benoît parce que juste un truc c'est
non parce que j'ai lu beaucoup de choses
en préparant sur cette émission et il y
a un phénomène qui arrive et j'aimerais
prévenir les parents vraiment les mots
m'ont entre 20 22 23 ans et aujourd'hui
je sais pas pourquoi à 223 ans tous les
momes sont persuadés qui sont vieux et
ils ont peur de vieillir et ils veulent
faire ce qu'on appelle aux États-Unis le
Baby Face absolument et donc à 22 23 ans
et Benoît veut ça pardon autant dire il
veut des bêtes il veut des jeux de bébé
des dents de bébé il a 32 ans il veut
ressembler à un môme de 20 ans déjà
aujourd'hui donc ils veulent des roues
un peu des joues un peu rondes ça c'est
ce qui arrive ce qui est demandé le plus
tort moi j'ai commencé la chirurgie très
très jeune déjà parce que je suis
confronté à mon reflet depuis mes 21 ans
c'est à dire que je vois sur mes réseaux
sociaux je vois dans la presse je vois
dans les médias je me vois vieillir
beaucoup plus que quelqu'un qui ne
travaille pas dans les médias donc moi
déjà c'est un vrai problème avec le
temps qui passe donc j'y vais et
effectivement quand j'ai à mon
chirurgien je lui dis à chaque fois je
m'en cache pas rendez-moi plus jeune je
veux une mâchoire d'Apollon et jouer des
petites joues de bébé et il me le fait
mais toujours avec j'ai refait le nez
j'ai refait plein de choses j'ai pu la
changer oui mais je m'en cache pas après
est-ce que je vais en faire à outrance
comme aux États-Unis on est vraiment sur
quelque chose de tout net on est tombé
dessus
toujours plus jeune ah bah là j'étais
oui et l'autre problème Benoît c'est
pour ça que j'aimerais
hypocrite de dire autour de la table
qu'on en a pas tous
en feras maintenant tu crois que
Michel-Ange il a touché la chapelle six
mais c'est ce qui pourrait
être sérieux je te donne la parole mais
parce qu'après elle m'a demandé autre
chose au médecin une seconde merci
Docteur Franky c'est comment reconnaître
un bon chirurgien parce que du coup
puisque on est sur le petit du haut noir
une fois NRJ12 il arrive et il me dit il
était content comme tout il avait trouvé
un mec sur Instagram qui lui avait fait
du Botox donc il arrive aussi attention
c'était quelqu'un connu et qui je ne dis
pas de nom il a les sourcils comme ça et
un qui est un peu plus bas mais je
dirais qu'il y a plus bas Benoît oui je
sais tu peux plus les bouger bah je dis
là tu es quoi tu es content
fais-moi un truc non mais non faut
savoir que quand on fait une injection
de Botox c'est un premier rendez-vous on
est injecté et une semaine après
maintenant tu viens faire une petite
retouche effectivement c'est un muscle
ou tu le détectes chirurgien non mais
bien sûr gratuitement
c'est pas ma boulangère dans son arrière
boutique il a fait la des diplôme
j'aimerais essayer de répondre à la
question qui est derrière toi les stars
sont-elles obligées de passer par la
case chirurgie et je vais reprendre
enfin rebondir sur ce qu'a dit Monsieur
moi j'ai rencontré un chirurgien pas
longtemps qui est spécialisé dans les
stars et qui envoie à longueur de
journée il m'a dit une chose en fait
elles en font toutes Aujourd'hui nous
d'ailleurs dans la presse people avant
c'était un peu un marronnier on en
parlait beaucoup on en parle plus parce
qu'elles en font toutes non quasiment
pour une raison très simple c'est que
c'est plus la chirurgie d'avant
aujourd'hui ce qu'elles font c'est des
petites retouches qui ne se voient pas
et qui les rendent l'air de rien
c'est très important il y a pas de beau
ou de vilain nez il m'a dit il y a des
nez qui prennent bien la lumière
le plus aujourd'hui justement bah moi je
trouve que je suis spécialisé dans
toutes sortes de lifting c'était le nez
donc moi je fais beaucoup de neige
encore
et on tire comme ça existera toujours et
comme vous disiez on sera contre
jusqu'au jour on en a besoin
d'accords
les fesses oui mais bien sûr toutes les
fesses de mesurer mais on n'est pas
obligé d'accepter moi je leur dis non
désolé ce que vous me demandez ça
n'existe pas dans la nature donc ce
n'est pas moi qui vous le ferai et je
vous déconseille de le faire alors
attends juste un petit zombie
sur les fesses parce que moi que je
quand il y a eu la mode qui a commencé
au Brésil des fois remboursé par la
pensée on disait ça n'arrivera pas en
France parce que les chirurgiens
français refuseront de faire ça parce
que c'est une zone qu'on sollicite
beaucoup et il y a des drames et or on
le voit maintenant se faire faire
régulièrement en France bien sûr donc il
y a une vraie dérive qui est en train de
s'installer avec la caution des médecins
parce qu'il y a de l'argent oui je sais
pas si c'est une dérive il y a des
femmes chez qui c'est justifié des
femmes qui sont jeunes qui ont des
fesses tout à fait plates et qui ont de
la graisse par ailleurs on prélève la
graisse là où il y en a trop on a
réinjecte où il y en a pas assez là
c'est justifié après sur les
complications
les techniques ont quand même beaucoup
évolué mais pour les mamans par exemple
le docteur les mains pour les mamans
quand même c'est on parlait la semaine
dernière comment retrouver sa ligne
rapidement je reconnais que si on peut
leur donner un petit coup de main si on
peut opérer maintenant après qu'elles
aient opérés tout ça après qu'elles a
accouché ça c'est plutôt c'est plutôt
très bien très très bien ça quand même
encore une fois les États-Unis et le
meilleur la chirurgien personnellement
j'ai voulu me faire opérer à un moment
donné quand j'étais en surpoids le
chirurgien a refusé c'est une question
il a refusé il m'a dit madame je suis
désolé vous allez d'abord aller perdre
du poids et ensuite vous reviendrez me
voir c'est fait pour parfaire c'est pas
fait pour tout enlever alors Jean-Mi qui
a fait aussi pas mal de choses il faut
quand même que ceux qui sont contre en
général c'est ceux qu'on n'ont pas
besoin mais je suis désolé quand on
nourrit des complexes moi je complexé de
perdre mes cheveux voilà et je me suis
dit il y a des techniques qui existent
qui sont maintenant éprouvées qui
permettent de résoudre ce problème je
l'ai fait je le regrette pas une seule
seconde j'avais les paupières qui
tombaient sur les yeux on fait quand
même un métier d'image notre corps c'est
quand même un peu notre capital quelque
part voilà donc j'avais des paupières
qui tombaient j'ai fait l'opération j'ai
bien évidemment bien choisi mon
chirurgien je crois que ça s'est bien
passé parce que la différence est
vraiment flagrante j'ai fait aussi
liposuccion je n'arrivais pas perdre du
poids parce que je faisais pas de sport
voilà la chirurgie moi je craque dessus
j'aimerais avoir j'aimerais modindra
Hydra quand vous aviez c'est vrai aussi
que la chanson cartonnée mais vous étiez
très jolie vous dansez sur scène et
forcément un producteur un peu con qui a
dû vous dire un jour ah dis donc tu
commences un petit peu à vieillir on est
un petit peu moins demandé dans les gala
et les machins est-ce que malgré tout
vous avez vous avez vous vous êtes dit
qu'il fallait rester un peu plus jeune
c'est-à-dire c'était après le
divorcement de mon mari donc je pense
qu'avec les soucis j'avais déjà des
indications pour faire un Botox puisque
je voulais reprendre ma carrière donc je
me suis dit je fais comme mais pour
reprendre sa carrière et en gros les
producteurs vous disent ça serait bien
que tu fêtes un peu de médecine
esthétique refaire les seins enfin pas
trop quand même je pense que mon
entourage a été assez à respecter la
nature mais des petits minimum quoi et
même moi je me suis dit bon Botox papa
quelque chose de plus lisse et c'est
vrai que la première fois c'était
fantastique
pour les gens qui comprennent bien que
ce qu'on appelle la médecine esthétique
c'est les injections c'est là où il y a
pas de bitury en fait
du coup c'est le nez les paupières les
oreilles voilà pour bien la différence
oui là-bas mais qu'est-ce qu'il y a mon
petit
cœur je vois non mais ça me fait de la
peine de voir les dérives en fait et
c'est vrai qu'on va pas se mentir les
femmes on est assez sous pression quand
on fait les images entre autres c'est
vrai qu'on a pas tellement envie de
vieillir donc on a envie un petit peu de
de profiter de ce qu'on peut nous
proposer donc aider un petit peu voilà
le temps à ralentir maintenant quand
j'entends Benoît dire on m'a proposé un
partenariat
mais c'est très bien mais c'est quand
même ton visage
mais quand tu vas avoir un professionnel
en général tu te retrouves pas avec un
sourcil ça peut le corps réagit
différemment
docteur est-ce que ça vous choque quand
vous entendez un garçon comme ça que 25
ans à l'époque on reste quand même la
médecine il y a toujours un danger même
une petite anesthésie en temps d'un
médecin vous dire parler de partenariat
de beauté enfin lui il achète ça qui me
l'acheter un truc chez Lidl c'est gratos
c'est pas comme ça que je fonctionne
je savais que ça existait que ça existe
j'ai pas de commentaires à faire
malade tu as vu un médecin tu le
connaissais pas tu voulais faire des
choses est-ce qu'on est en train de dire
aussi pour les gens qui nous regardent
il y a des dérives il peut y avoir des
ratés
c'est très compliqué de le régler
elles font toutes sortes
les partenariats
on est obligé malheureusement de prendre
des chirurgiens qui font des opérations
à des coûts très réduits ou à l'étranger
etc et qui du coup ça s'intéresse au
moins bien
coûtent cher alors là je vais me mettre
ça parce que les médecins marocains
tunisiens et tout sont moins moins
qualifiés que les médecins français ça
c'est très intéressant alors quand c'est
pas cher il y a un piège esthétique la
chirurgie esthétique low cost depuis
d'Angers on a une chance en France c'est
qu'on a le pays qui a la meilleure
sécurité en matière de chirurgie
esthétique au monde numéro 1 au monde en
matière de sécurité donc c'est pas
logique d'aller se faire opérer à
l'étranger je comprends que pour
économiser quelques centaines d'euros
quelques milliers d'euros parfois il y
ait des patients des patients le
problème c'est que et j'en vois beaucoup
à mon cabinet régulièrement et mes
collègues aussi le problème c'est que
ces patients et patientes reviennent en
France certains sont satisfaits
satisfaites d'autres pas du tout se
rendre compte que c'est pas du tout ce
qu'il voulait que les cicatrices sont
moches que les seins sont de travers que
il faut tout reprendre donc vous avez
beaucoup vous justement dans la médecine
réparatrice de la chirurgie enfin
évidemment que j'en ai et parfois je dis
bah écoutez non je suis pas capable de
réparer ça ou je ne veux pas me lancer
dedans et quand je me lance dedans
malheureusement ma grand-mère disait
acheter mon marché s'est acheté deux
fois là en chirurgie esthétique acheter
bon marché payer bon marché c'est payé 3
fois parce que si vous payez une somme X
en Tunisie au Maroc en Turquie ou peu
importe et que vous revenez et que le
résultat n'est pas du tout à la hauteur
de vos espaces bien sûr vous payez le
double
il y a juste un petit mot de quelqu'un
de ta famille qui a fait des choses en
Tunisie oui bah là c'est les dents ta
maman on peut dire ta maman elle avait
pas les moyens du tout elle est partie
ça c'est pas vraiment très bien passé
parce que ils ont mis des strips il y a
une cicatrice qui était plutôt Vilaine
et elle est à Paris à la repayer une
seconde chirurgie lui refait les
cicatrices et maintenant c'est nickel
elle a fait les dents mais du coup
partenariat les dents mais du coup c'est
deux fois ta mère
quand elle est revenue et sa mère quand
elle est revenue elle m'a dit les dents
elles sont un peu trop blanches ça peut
machin mais voilà sa mère elle gagne le
SMIC bah elle pouvait pas c'est à dire
en France les dents sont pas pris en
charge sont très bien et c'est à dire
que les femmes qui ont des vilaines
dents peuvent avoir une vie sociale pour
travailler pour trouver l'amour enfin
les dents c'est quelque chose qui vous
donne confiance en vous et en France
c'est pas du tout prix
merci oui Isabelle tu vas finir
quand on voit des jeunes qui est arrivé
avec une photo d'Avatar
je voudrais je voudrais avoir ce visage
là alors que c'est totalement du fait si
je veux dire forcément le visage
n'existe pas dans la réalité
est-ce que toi tu as déjà pensé à
quelque chose que j'avais fait trop cher
pourquoi tu l'as jamais fait c'est
pourquoi ça t'a jamais tenté est-ce que
tu avais un complexe on a tous des
complexes j'en ai plein plein il y aura
une émission ne suffirait pas
[Rires]
conduire j'ai toujours eu trop de boulot
donc j'ai jamais accepté de faire
quelque chose aujourd'hui tu ferais quoi
tout non mais un truc tout remonté
c'est avoir un mari qu'elle a vu qui
baise je t'assure ça remet plein de
trucs en place
[Applaudissements]
de nombre d'amis qu'on mon âge ou
vieille amie d'amis ma femme qui ce
qu'on fait les lèvres qu'on fait l'élève
notamment c'est horrible et où tu te dis
mais à quel moment mais si on regarde le
matin la glace et il y a pas quelqu'un
qui leur dit mais je suis d'accord
10 ans de plus et vouloir faire 50 moins
mais en fait en réalité et en vrai et
pourquoi personne leur dit jamais bien
sûr bien sûr
que j'aimerais dire à mort c'est docteur
vous avez confirmé ce que je dis mais il
y a un médecin
de la médecine esthétique on en sait sur
un visage il en reste toujours un peu
donc on va en refaire sur un visage qui
cette fois avait déjà été un peu modifié
puis on aurait fait sur un visage
modifié et nous on ne voit plus ce qu'on
se ce corps se modifie et c'est qu'un
jour un jour tu as un bob Danov et nous
on voit que c'est des Bogdanov mais toi
dans ta glace tu vois le visage
notre rôle c'est de dire stop non là on
sort du cadre de ce qui est naturel si
ce n'est pas naturel vous allez avoir
l'effet inverse c'est à dire qu'au lieu
d'attirer les gens de de d'inspirer la
beauté d'inspirer la question
aujourd'hui excusez-moi je vous connais
pas et je grand respect pour ce que vous
faites et j'imagine que vous êtes
certainement un type tout à fait non bah
c'est pas le cas de la plupart de vos
confrères excusez-moi bon moi nous on
connaît tous autour de nous plein de
gens qui font des choses tout autour de
nous à chaque fois ils vont tous voir
des médecins formidables vous connaissez
les noms par cœur à Paris et ailleurs
pardon mais c'est quand même j'y
retourne tous les quatre mois il m'a
encore proposé un truc robotox là
vous répondez vos confrères de l'argent
j'entends tout à fait ce que vous dites
attention il faut distinguer deux
métiers la chirurgie esthétique on est
très peu nombreux on fait de la
chirurgie on opère et le bistouri et on
fait aussi des injections acidia uriques
botox et puis il y a
un panel de médecins de tout spécialité
anesthésiste pédiatres médecin
généraliste etc qui gagnent pas très
bien leur vie en exerçant un métier
qu'ils aimaient et qui se
reconvertissent dans la médecine
esthétique et ça il est parfois il
improvise un petit peu et là c'est vrai
que on trouve de tout il y a des gens
sérieux et puis des gens moins sérieux
comme partout docteur merci surtout
docteur d'avoir été avec nous merci
ingra merci à tous samedi
[Applaudissements]